WITH US NOW MAGGIE HABERMAN CNN
POLITICAL ANALYST AND SENIOR
POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT FOR
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ON TWO HUGE
BY LINES IN MORNING, MAGGIE.
NICE TO HAVE YOU HERE WITH US.
FIRST, I DO WANT TO ASK ABOUT
YOUR REPORTING THAT AS PART OF
THIS GRAND JURY INVESTIGATION
THAT THESE WITNESSES HAVE BEEN
ASKED SPECIFICALLY ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP AND HIS ACTIONS.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S NEW.
LOOK, WE DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THAT
THEY WERE CALLING WITNESSES FROM
WITHIN THE WHITE HOUSE A FEW
DAYS AGO, NOW WE KNOW THEY'RE
HAVING WITNESSES AND HAVE BEEN
ASKING ABOUT TRUMP.
THE SIGNIFICANCE?
>> JOHN, IT CERTAINLY GETS
CLOSER TO FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR ON THIS, WE
DON'T KNOW IF THERE IS A
SPECIFIC INVESTIGATION INTO
DONALD TRUMP, BUT ALL OF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS RELATE TO THINGS
THAT EITHER HE, YOU KNOW, HELPED
PUT IN MOTION OR ENCOURAGED AND
SO THESE ARE WITNESSES WHO ARE
BEING ASKED ABOUT CONVERSATIONS
WITH HIM.
IT DOES SUGGEST THAT THE DOJ IS
MOVING CLOSER TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, IT DOES SUGGEST THAT
THEY ARE TAKING VERY SERIOUSLY
EXAMINING ALL ASPECTS OF THIS.
I THINK THE PHONE RECORDS PIECE,
TOO, JOHN, IS VERY SIGNIFICANT.
I THINK THIS LOOKS AT WHO WAS
TALKING TO WHOM, EXACTLY WHAT
WAS TAKING PLACE AROUND THAT
TIME, YOU KNOW, I THINK ALL OF
THIS, YOU KNOW, JUST SUGGESTS,
AGAIN, THAT THERE IS STEADY
MOVEMENT TOWARD FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE, AS YOU
SAY, IT WOULD BE UNPRECEDENTED
IF THERE WAS AN ACTUAL
INDICTMENT, BUT THERE IS
DEFINITELY AN INVESTIGATION
UNDER WAY.
>> IF YOU'RE GOING TO WALK
BACKWARDS FROM AN INDICTMENT
OBVIOUSLY DOJ WOULD HAVE TO BE
LOOKING AT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
CONDUCT AROUND OR ON JANUARY 6th
BUT AT THE SAME TIME IT'S BEEN A
LONG TIME COMING THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE GOTTEN TO THIS POINT,
MAGGIE.
>> LOOK, THEY'VE BEEN METHODICAL
ABOUT WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN DOING,
I THINK WE HAVE SEEN THAT.
IT CERTAINLY IS 18 MONTHS AND I
THINK SINCE THE RIOT AT THE
CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6th AND I
DON'T THINK A TON OF INFORMATION
HAS CHANGED ABOUT THAT, BUT I
THINK THAT AS YOU SAW GARLAND
SAY, THIS INVESTIGATION IS
UNPRECEDENTED IN SCOPE, THEY ARE
LOOKING NOT JUST AT WHAT WAS
TAKING PLACE IN THE WHITE HOUSE
BUT HOW THOSE VARIOUS PIECES
OVERLAP WITH THE RIOTERS IF THEY
DO, HOW THE PIECES OVERLAP WITH
THIS, YOU KNOW, SO-CALLED FAKE
ELECTORS SCHEME.
SO I THINK THAT THEY ARE LOOKING
AT HOW THESE VARIOUS PIECES OF
PUZZLE FIT TOGETHER AND HOW
THOSE PIECES RELATE TO DONALD
TRUMP SPECIFICALLY.
>> AND WE'VE USED CAREFUL
LANGUAGE, MAGGIE, WE ARE NOT
SAYING THEY ARE INVESTIGATING
THE PRESIDENT.
YOU ARE NOT SAYING THAT.
BUT THERE IS REPORTING NOW THAT
THEY ARE ASKING ABOUT THINGS
THAT HE WAS INVOLVED IN AND
THAT'S DIFFERENT, VERY
DIFFERENT, THAN WE KNEW AT LEAST
EVEN A FEW DAYS AGO.
MAGGIE, YOUR OTHER REPORTING
HERE, I WANT YOU TO DESCRIBE IT
AND THEN I CAN READ SOME OF THE
EMAILS THAT YOU REVEALED TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FOR THE VERY
FIRST TIME.
THESE ARE EMAILS BETWEEN TRUMP
ADVISERS AND OTHER PEOPLE OUT
THERE IN THE STATES HAVING TO
DEAL WITH WHAT THEY CALLED THE
FAKE ELECTORS SCHEME.
>> THIS IS A TRANCHE OF EMAILS
THAT LUKE BROADWATER AND I
REVIEWED AND THERE WERE DOZENS
OF PAGES IN WHICH YOU HAVE THESE
LAWYERS WHO WERE WORKING WITH A
WING OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN,
THERE APPEAR TO BE PEOPLE WHO
DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT IT,
BOTH WITHIN THE WHITE HOUSE AND
ON THE CAMPAIGN, BUT WORKING
WITHIN THIS WING TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO SEND THESE
SLATES OF, QUOTE, UNQUOTE, FAKE
ELECTORS TO CONGRESS ON JANUARY
6th.
WHY DO WE USE THE WORD FAKE?
BECAUSE ONE OF THE LAWYERS IN
THIS EMAIL TRANCHE WORKING OUT
OF ARIZONA USED THE WORD FAKE IN
QUOTES TO DESCRIBE THESE
ELECTORS SAYING THEY WOULD BE,
YOU KNOW, FAKE BECAUSE THEY
WOULD NOT BE LEGAL UNDER THE LAW
WHICH SAYS THEY HAD TO BE
APPROVED OR SIGNED INTO --
RECOGNIZED BY THE GOVERNOR.
NOW, THE LAWYER DID GO ON TO SAY
THAT HE THOUGHT LEGALLY THIS WAS
ACCEPTABLE TO CONTINUE WITH THIS
PLAN, BUT THE FACT THAT HE WROTE
ALL OF THIS IS GOING TO RAISE
ALL KINDS OF QUESTIONS ABOUT
EXACTLY WHAT PEOPLE THOUGHT THEY
WERE DOING.
AND THE OTHER POINT I'D RAISE,
JOHN, IS FOLKS INVOLVED IN THIS
SCHEME HAVE SUGGESTED THEY WERE
DOING THIS AS A CONTINGENCY
PLAN.
THIS WAS JUST IF COURT
CHALLENGES CAME THROUGH THEN
THEY HAD THIS SLATE OF ELECTORS.
THESE EMAILS REVEAL THAT THE
LAWYERS WERE TALKING ABOUT
KEEPING THIS UNDER WRAPS AS LONG
AS POSSIBLE AND OUT OF THE
MEDIA'S VIEW, THAT DOESN'T SOUND
LIKE IT RELATES TO A COURT
CHALLENGE.
>> ALSO THERE WERE PEOPLE VERY
COMMITTED TO THE ELECTION LIE
WHO WERE QUEASY ABOUT THIS.
DOUG MASTRIANO WHO WAS A STATE
SENATOR, NOW RUNNING FOR
GOVERNOR IN PENNSYLVANIA, HUGELY
COMMITTED TO THE ELECTION LIE
AND HE WAS CONCERNED.
>> RIGHT.
THERE'S AN EMAIL WHERE CHRISTINA
BOB WHO AT THE TIME WAS WORKING
FOR OAN NEWS, NOW WORKS WITH ONE
OF DONALD TRUMP'S POLITICAL
ENTITIES, SENT AN EMAIL TO
OTHERS SAYING THAT MASTRIANO WHO
IS NOW THE GOP CANDIDATE FOR
GOVERNOR IN PENNSYLVANIA WHO WAS
ONE OF THE POINTS OF CONTACT
THEY WERE LOOKING FOR FOR THESE
SLATES OF ELECTORS, THAT HE
NEEDED REASSURANCE, THAT HE
NEEDED A PHONE CALL FROM RUDY
GIULIANI, HE NEEDED TO BE
REASSURED THAT THIS WAS, QUOTE,
A, LEGAL AND, B, ESSENTIAL TO
STRATEGY.
THAT'S ALSO VERY TELLING, AS YOU
SAY, ABOUT PEOPLE'S CONCERNS
ABOUT WHAT THEY WERE GETTING
INVOLVED IN.
>> MAGGIE HABERMAN, GREAT TO SEE
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING YOUR
REPORTING WITH US.
>> THANK YOU.